none other than the co-owner of stuart
haas racing as well
as a hall of famer the pride of
indiana himself tony stewart here on the
rich either show how are you tony
man i'm great hanging in there and
trying to live
life a little different than what we're
all used to but at the same time we're
still
excited that you know we're all able to
race and excited for the indy 500 this
weekend
what was the first time you walked into
the brickyard you remember that
oh my god as a kid um i'm not even sure
what year was but i went with my father
i think the first time was to
one of the qualifying days and i
remember
at a separate year my dad taken me to
the race and we sat on the front row of
turns three and four which
you can't see a lot from there but
everything that went by went by really
fast
so uh had a great appreciation at a
young age
you know for for the indianapolis motor
speedway and indy 500.
i bet i bet so you know growing up
i guess who was your favorite racer
there
aj aj foyt aj
is a badass man he was a badass aj foyt
i remember that i remember watching wild
world of sports growing up right
and listening to you know jackie stewart
right and chris economaki on the mic and
doing the
doing the race i just i i lived for it i
loved it
loved every second of it tony you know
yeah i did too i
mean i i every year even when i
had the first opportunity in 96 to race
in indianapolis and
and you know remember all the pageantry
and everything leading up to it i mean i
i i was a wreck i didn't even know how i
was going to drive the car in the race
like ever at the practice days
qualifying all that was pretty sanitary
insane
and and then you get to race day and you
have all the pre-race pageantry and
everything
going on and it was like just please
tell me to get in the car so i can drive
now because it's driving me quick
so uh i was i was glad when we finally
got to
got to that point i bet i bet tell me
about the day
where you ran uh in the brickyard
and then uh took care of some nascar
responsibilities where you
you actually took care of two races in
one day walk me through that one
tony uh makes for a long day i can tell
you that
actually when you know the indy 500's in
in indiana and then you fly down to
charlotte north carolina to run the
coca-cola 600 which is nascar's longest
race of the year
so um you know it's just uh i did it
twice i did it 99 the first year and
then did it again in 2001 and
and uh not a guy that's a big workout
guy
i just was kind of old school like aj
point was i guess
in that regard but um just literally it
was
didn't i was so nervous about being
dehydrated i didn't eat enough solid
food during the day and it really got to
me
at the end of the 600 but it's a long
day i mean the hardest part is probably
uh running the indy 500 for me because i
was so used to being in the stock car
every week at that point that you know
being in an indy car just one time that
year
for the 500 was the hardest part of it
but you get done with that you
get on a helicopter you fly to the to
the india airport you get on an airplane
you fly down to the concord airport
get on another helicopter and land in
the infield of the racetrack so
uh you know just makes for a very very
long day it took a lot of people that
that made the logistics happen but the
second time we did it we had a trainer
that went with us
you know we got clearance uh on the
flight to once we took off from
from indianapolis once we got in here we
were direct all the way to concord
didn't have any junctions to make
so it was a 44 minute flight down there
but having a trainer and having a
medical staff to make sure they got iv
fluids in me during that flight and
making sure that i had the right foods
to eat to help me get through the next
600 mile race was a big part of it
yeah i mean to do the indy 500 and then
fly to a totally different state and
then
as you point out the longest race for
nascar i mean
that is uh you gotta you gotta love
racing and i i just
you know i just drove up to see my mom
up in uh
you know the uh the east bay in northern
california
just drove it straight my back was
killing me i mean literally about three
four hours in but i'm a 50 year old guy
though you know what i'm saying
i can't imagine what you did it's
impressive well it's
you know and so that's perfect example i
mean everybody thinks it's just like
driving a streetcar the the seats and
the race cars both the indy car and the
stock car yeah
you know our form fit to you so it's
it's the most comfortable seat you're
going to be in
from that stance but you just it's like
anything else any other sport whether
it's football basketball baseball i mean
you have to be
prepared for it and season for it and
you know being in a race car three days
a week every weekend
like i was running you know you were in
shape for it and ready for it so
you know the biggest thing was just the
nutrition side of it making sure that in
between the races we were getting
rehydrated uh which we were getting the
advantage of iv fluids to help us with
that and
and making sure we were eating the right
foods that were going to help us with
the energy we needed to run
a four-hour 600-mile race in charlotte
after the 500 was
you know having that preparation and
having those people in place to help us
get ready for that you know made that
all possible tony stewart here on the
rich eisen show fortunate enough before
the pandemic
truly hit uh inducted into the nascar
hall of fame
um this past january and none other than
jimmy johnson
uh doing the inducting
where does jimmy rank in terms of guys
that uh
you have raced against tony
uh he's in the he's in the top five for
sure um
you know and and it's not always just
about what he does on the racetrack it's
all the stuff he does off the racetrack
and the kind of person he is off the
racetrack i mean i consider him a great
friend and
somebody that i admire i mean he
whatever it is he chooses to do
in his life whether it's his personal
life whether it's his professional life
he gives a hundred and ten percent to it
and and
you know he works hard at every aspect
of it the things that he does i mean
i'm lucky if i woke up in time to even
have a meal before i would get up in the
morning for practice
jimmy on the other hand would have
already rode a 60 to 100 mile bike ride
came back probably jogged 10 miles and
then got up and
got a shower got it got breakfast and
then got ready for practice so i mean
he's just one of those guys that
um you know he's he's definitely getting
the most out of life right now for sure
well he's
talked about um you know uh flying with
you
once upon a time uh eating hamburgers
with you so are you saying that was out
of character for jimmy to
to be chowing uh burgers like that yeah
on your jet yeah
to watch him eat a hamburger it's like a
foreign object to him so he
to me it's like man i where's the
closest mcdonald's or wendy's or burger
king or something
jimmy john's i'm hungry so um you know
to sit there and watch jimmy
eat a cheeseburger like that he's he's
like this is all you have i'm like
what do you mean i mean what more would
you want yeah
that's the way i'm comfortable no i know
it man come hang out with me for a week
he goes i get you straight down i'm like
absolutely not i'm not getting
well he also said that in in on that
plane ride you were feeding your dogs
filet mignon while he was eating burgers
is that a true story too
tony why that happened but the dog got
the got the steak and i got the
cheeseburger or something so
but i love my dogs too so i'll do
anything for my
i i am with you on that front sir um
you know uh our our dog i think my wife
likes dogs more than people
i think personally you know that's
entirely possible
i've always just liked the saying that
you could sit there and take your dog
and take your girlfriend and put them in
the trunk and two hours later open the
trunk and see which one's actually happy
to see you
i mean that tells the story right there
[Laughter]
tony stewart everybody here
on the rich eisen show uh okay so this
indy 500
uh what what are you most looking
forward to um
i mean you want to talk about unique um
this is
we're talking august we're talking at
empty brickyard you know
so what do you what are you expecting
out of this one
well i mean it's definitely different
for sure i mean this isn't this isn't
the year that
any of us in any professional sport have
wanted to see on any
standpoint but um you know i think uh
what i'm excited about i mean
i'm super excited about what advanced
auto parts and die hard batteries are
doing
i mean it's it's a year where it just
wasn't possible to have fans at the race
and uh you know advanced auto parts and
die hard batteries figured out a way to
try to get the fans engaged and
make them a part of the pre-race
ceremonies and and the command
to start your engines and having the
promotion of
callingalldiehards.com if you get on
there and send in a video of your
committee
of your command for the drivers to start
their engines
you have a chance to be that person that
gets to start the starting field and
and uh if you don't make that then the
next 50 people get 200
gift certificates uh for die hard
batteries or any products that
advance auto parts have at their stores
so it's a pretty cool promotion and i
think it's something where
it shows how much advanced auto parts
are celebrating the the 50 years that
die hard batteries have been at the
indianapolis motor speedway
starting the entire 33 car starting
field and celebrating their fifth years
of commitment to the indianapolis 500 so
to have those guys partner up and
you know to have the fans be able to be
a part of the indy 500 even though we
can't be there in person
to have that promotion and have these
people have an opportunity to
participate i think is
is about as good as you could possibly
ask for so really proud of advance
uh and and you know die hard for for
participating in this and
helping bring the experience back to the
people calling alldiehards.com
through advanced auto parts is there any
tips you can give tony as somebody who's
heard this
for a long time you're a native from
indiana
um this is a very serious uh business of
telling someone to start their engines
do you
is there a word is there a word that
that you should you'd suggest somebody
could
you know accent is it is it uh start
is it your engines i mean walk me
through what you think would make a very
good
call on this front well i was i was
telling doug bowles from annapolis motor
speedway today i said i i was what i was
most grateful of was
when i was a driver and heard that
command was i was glad that the cars
didn't have carburetors on them i'm glad
they were just fuel injected because if
they were carburetors
my foot was bouncing on the throttle
pedal so hard from nerves
and my legs shaking that it would have
flooded the motor so
i'm glad they were fuel injected where
there wasn't any fuel going in there too
oh we just lost tony right there
interesting that he says just as we say
start your engines
right in the middle of all that well
okay let's see if he'll call back
lost him right there if you want to pop
on pop on there christopher see if he's
still there
i think we lost him hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here